Tasha: 嗯他还知道种水
Tasha: Hmm, he even knows about jade types.
其他人：豆种哈哈哈
Others: Bean type, hahaha.
Tasha: 都种是什么意思
Tasha: What does bean type mean?
其他人：豆种呀豆种糯种冰种水种
Others: Bean type, bean type, glutinous type, ice type, water type.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Alice:你家做这个的吗
Alice: Does your family do this?
其他人：没有天天刷小视频
Others: No, I just watch short videos every day.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈给你女朋友买是吗
Tasha: Hahaha, are you buying it for your girlfriend?
Jake:学专家了是吧
Jake: Becoming an expert, huh?
Jake:就学成专家了
Jake: Just learned to be an expert.
Jake:自学成才自学成才
Jake: Self-taught, self-taught.
其他人：我给女朋友买不起这些东西
Others: I can't afford these things for my girlfriend.
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: Ah ha.
其他人：我女朋友手上全都是
Others: My girlfriend's hands are full of them.
Jake:哦这么牛逼
Jake: Oh, so impressive.
Tasha: 啊真的吗
Tasha: Oh, really?